every year Apple brings thousands of its
developers San Francisco and walks them
through platform by platform the future
of its software we don't see iPads we
don't see iPhones did we get the
ecosystem the backbones that power all
of that stuff and this year there was a
lot of it it started with OS 10 and iOS
updates called El Capitan and iOS 9
respectively they're mostly performance
updates nothing huge they're faster and
more efficient and there's transit
directions and maps now which is
actually pretty awesome there was also a
personal assistant for iOS it's designed
to take your email and your calendar and
your browsing history and your contacts
list and give you all the information
you need at any given time it's apple's
response to microsoft cortana and google
now and it's really designed to bring
your phone together and make it a little
smarter and a little more efficient
apple also released a new app called
News which is designed to be basically
like Flipboard it's the most beautiful
put together app with all the
publications and writers and topics that
you love it's the one place you can just
open up and always find something to
read and the watch just came out a
couple of months ago but it's already
getting a huge update and the biggest
change is that there are now native apps
which means apps can run on the watch
itself apple also made big steps to turn
the iPad into something more like a real
computer you can do multitasking with
two apps side-by-side you can do picture
and picture while you watch the video
and use an app full screen you can use
two fingers on the screen and use it
like a touchpad it's just much more like
a macbook now than an iphone and the
iPads never really been that way before
Apple music was the biggest by far it
was the one more thing the last
announcement but it was the biggest one
it's part itunes in the cloud where you
can stream any song on earth for ten
dollars a month and part one global
radio station that everyone can listen
to album music's coming out june
thirtieth but the real potential for
this stuff is going to be realized by
the developers were in that room in the
Moscone Center they're the people who
get their hands on this stuff now and
they're the ones who build the cool
weird funky different things for these
platforms that are going to be really
what change how we use our devices next
year
you